so Kate right from the opening line in
this film I do you want to give it away
do you want to say it
oh no you'll have to bleep it we can get
away with that I'm back you bastards
right from that opening line
I suddenly realized this is a completely
different film did you get that from
yeah I did I loved it I really loved it
and actually the script went through a
couple of drafts after the original one
that I had said oh yes I really want to
be a part of this and Jocelyn Morehouse
had included a few a few scenes right
before that moment and I said no no no
we've got to we've got to keep it that
way it's such a great beginning because
for me it was just it was just
unflinchingly what it was it was she
there she is that's who she is and she's
back and and I love the strength in it I
really did it's probably one of the best
opening lines in any film this year I
mean it really so yeah throws you in
that you said the film the tone of it
though it's bonkers but yeah it's kind
of it kind of works but don't you love
that I did it's so nice to see something
there's lovely to be a part of something
that is quite bonkers in that way you
know it has sort of touches of almost
Priscilla Queen of the desert just in
how it looks and also just how wild it
sometimes feels and it's a fable you
know it's a fable it's it's it's it's
not real and so within that there was
lots of artistic creative license that
was taken for example Hugo Weaving plays
a policeman gets arrested wearing a
Matadors outfit I mean it's just
fantastic and it was so lovely and quite
liberating to be a part of something
like that
the Australian accent we all think in
England we can do in Australian accent
because we've been brought up watching
neighbors and all that kind of stuff was
it so you never made it to Ramsay Street
what's going to go one day and then
someone said you know it's like a
three-hour drive I've seen on TV but
I'll just go out for lunch with Guy
Pearce instead how difficult is that
accent legs real you know the sort of
g'day mate yeah we can all do that but
keeping up and making it believable and
not a caricature of the axis well it's
time in doing accent I love doing
accents but it you know that some of
them are harder than others
an Australian this type of Australian it
was quite hard because actually it isn't
too heavy it isn't kind of there is a
sort of a
our lightness to it and you know my
intention with any accent really is just
to make it sort of disappear you know
you just don't want the audience to hear
you doing it you just want it to be
there and then go and so yeah I mean I
just I worked with a dialect coach and
you know did the normal thing I would do
to try and get it as good as I could the
hardest thing to be honest was not
slipping into New Zealand because Kerry
Fox who's also in the film who plays
Tilly's old schoolteacher Beulah Hardeen
she is a New Zealander and she does I
haven't got a very strong accent and
it's like oh god Kerry and so I have a
scene with her and actually I ended up
doing a lot of ADR additional dialogue
recording after the film is shot
specifically on that one scene because I
completely became a Kiwi it was just
carry a knife or four pages straight and
absolutely
my character suddenly was a New
Zealander it was a nightmare
just finally your character's an
Australian obviously and a very sexy
Australian if I write very much you
really sort of amp this up it has that
sort of old-school Hollywood siren you
enjoyed knowing that I mapped it yeah I
loved it and you know playing a
character whose identity is so bound up
in what she wears you know those clothes
are almost like her glamorous armor in a
way it was really really fantastic you
know it's a little time consuming making
sure the hair and the makeup was perfect
and the costumes and but all of those
things were a real thrill for me and
everything that Tilly wears is a
reflection of who she is and what she's
gone through and and the creations that
she that she comes up with for the rest
of the towns folk it was a lot of fun
actually being involved in that process
as well much more than I normally would
so no it was fantastic